so we have the graph here of y is equal
to p of x i could write it like this y
is equal to
p of x and they say what is the
remainder when p of x is divided by x
plus three so pause this video and see
if you can have a go at this and they
tell us your answer should be an integer
so as you might have assumed this will
involve the polynomial remainder theorem
and all that tells us is that hey if we
were to take p of x
and divided by x plus 3
whatever the remainder is here so let's
say the remainder is equal to k
that value k is what we would have
gotten if we took our polynomial and we
evaluated it at the value of x that
would have made x plus 3 equals 0 or
just what would happen if i evaluated
our polynomial at x equals negative 3.
you have to be very careful there
sometimes people get confused they see a
positive 3 and then they evaluate the
polynomial at the positive 3 to figure
out the remainder no you would if you
saw a positive 3 there you would
evaluate the polynomial at negative 3.
but this should be equal to k
as well
and so what is the remainder when p of x
is divided by x plus 3 well it's going
to be equal to
p of negative 3.
p of negative 3 it looks like it is
equal to negative 2 it is equal to
negative 2. so our remainder is equal to
negative 2 in this situation let's do
another example
actually let's do several more examples
here we're told that p of x is equal to
all of this business where k is an
unknown integer very interesting
p of x divided by x minus two has a
remainder of one
what is the value of k
so pause this video again see if you can
work it out
all right well this second sentence that
p of x divided by x minus two has a
remainder of one
that tells us that p of not of negative
two but p of positive two whatever x
value would make this expression equal
zero that p of 2 is equal to 1 and then
we could use this top information to
figure out what p of 2 would be it would
be 2 to the 4th power
minus 2 times
2 to the third power plus
k
times 2 squared so times
2 squared
minus 11 and so all of that that's p of
2 right over here that's going to be
equal to 1.
2 to the fourth is 16 and then 2 times 2
to the third that's 2 to the 4th again
so it's minus 16
plus 4k
minus 11 is equal to 1. these cancel out
and let's see we can add 11 to both
sides of this equation
and we
get
4 k
is equal to 12 divide both sides by 4
and we get k is equal to 3 and we're
done let's do another example in fact
let's do two more because we're having
so much fun
so this next question tells us
p of x is a polynomial and they tell us
what p of x divided by various things
are what the remainder would be when you
divide p of x by these various
expressions
find the following values of p of x p of
negative 4 and p of 1.
pause this video and see if you can have
a go at it
all right
so p
of negative 4
this is going to be equal to the
remainder
remainder
when
p of x
divided by
what
you might be tempted to say x minus 4
but they're trying to trick you
intentionally this would be the
remainder when p of x is divided by x
plus 4.
and so they tell us right over here p of
x divided by x plus 4 has a remainder of
3. so it's going to be 3 right over
there and similarly p of 1 this is going
to be the remainder this is the
remainder
when
p of x
divided by
not x plus 1 but x minus 1.
so when p of x is divided by x minus 1
the remainder is 0.
let's do one last example
so once again p of x is a polynomial and
then they give us a few values of p of x
and they say what is the remainder when
p of x is divided by x minus 3.
pause the video and try to think about
that
well we've gone over this multiple times
the remainder when p of x is divided by
x minus 3 that would be p of
not negative 3 p of positive 3. whatever
value makes whatever value of x makes
this entire expression equal 0. so p of
positive 3 p of positive 3 is equal to
5.
and similarly what is the remainder
actually no not so similar this is
interesting what is the remainder when p
of x is divided by x i know what you're
thinking is like wait what what what
number am i dealing with but if i were
to rewrite this instead of saying
divided by x if i were to say divided by
x plus 0 then you'd be like oh now i get
it or if i wrote divided by x minus 0
you're like oh now i get it this is
going to be
p of and it doesn't matter whether i
take a positive or a negative 0 it's
going to be p of 0 and p of 0 they tell
us is negative 1 and we're done